thanks in part to the San Diego
comic-con July saw the release of some
of the biggest movie trailers of the
year so far from a tantalizing first
look at Godzilla king of the monsters to
full-blown trailers for blockbusters
like overlord Shazam and fantastic
beasts to July came in like a lion and
left like a kaiju leaving a trail of
explosive movie mayhem in its wake in
fact there are almost too many to keep
track of so here's a rundown of all the
best trailers from July 2018 that are
guaranteed to get you excited a prayer
before dawn so far 8:24 is the studio
that can't seem to miss they've been
behind Oscar winners underground
favorites and blockbusters alike and
2018 sees them continuing that trend
with a prayer before dawn following a
British boxer who's sentenced to stay in
a violent Thailand prison the film looks
like a gritty character study and a
thrilling drama that won't pull any
punches early screenings have already
garnered a prayer before dawn an
impressive Rotten Tomatoes score and
mainstream audiences will get the chance
to witness the inspiring story when it
hits theaters on August 10th patient
zero after a relatively infection-free
couple years zombies are breaking out on
the big screen again with patient zero
Matt Smith plays an American soldier who
can communicate with the infected his
job is to sit down and chat with the
zombies in an attempt to figure out how
the whole plague works but he meets his
match when one zombie seems to be
different from all the rest it turns out
that zombies probably aren't zombies
after all they're more like smarter
humans who happen to be really violent I
don't think
really cure can humanity survive against
a better version of themselves
find out when patient zero goes straight
to streaming on August 14th
assassination nation seeming to revel in
its own controversy assassination nation
released its second trailer in July and
provided more glimpses into what's
shaping up to be a really weird movie
world the film centers on the breakdown
of civilized society in a small town
after a hacker releases a bunch of
emails and texts sent around by the
residents it's all-out war in the sleepy
suburbs after that and the trailer
descends into a montage of purged like
violence between neighbors and friends
take a look on September 21st Bohemian
Rhapsody each new trailer for Bohemian
Rhapsody reveals more details about the
story more glimpses of rami malek as
freddie mercury and best of all more
queen songs the hard-rocking biopic
follows the band from its humble origins
to the sold-out stadiums with a hard
focus on frontman Freddie Mercury Roger
there's only room in this band for one
hysterical Queen but of course there's a
dark side to every story in the latest
trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody spares a
few seconds to show that it's not all
foot-stomping crowd-pleasing fun for
this rock quartet Bohemian Rhapsody
doesn't look like it's going to shy away
from anything find out when it premieres
on November 2nd overlord despite all the
rumors and speculation producer JJ
Abrams has always said that Overlord
isn't a Cloverfield movie nobody
believes in but that's what he's saying
at least so maybe we can all just enjoy
it for what it is which is a world war 2
zombie movie is that so bad really the
trailer opens with a Plane full of
soldiers flying over the beaches of
Normandy
almost immediately they're shot down
sending a few of the unlucky troopers
parachuting deep behind enemy lines that
would be bad enough because Nazis but it
turns out that there have been some
devious Nazi experiments going on behind
closed doors
putting the intrepid band of soldiers
face to face with horrifying monsters it
looks like a bucket of fun and you can
check it out when Overlord hits theaters
on November 9th boy erased joel edgerton
made his first foray into writing
directing and acting all in the same
movie with 2015's the gift and his
upcoming film boy erased we'll see him
back in all those roles
time he'll be tackling the story of a
young man forced into gay conversion
therapy by his overbearing Baptist
father while Edgerton has a supporting
role the main cast is anchored by Nicole
Kidman and Russel Crowe who star as the
parents of Jared played by Lucas hedges
the trailer is an emotional gut punch
from start to finish with gripping
performances by everyone involved and
the fact that it's all based on a true
story twist the knife just a little bit
deeper take a look when it lands in
theatres on November 2nd fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald at this
point The Wizarding World of JK Rowling
couldn't be stopped even if you hit it
with an unforgivable curse in a year
filled with huge blockbusters fantastic
beasts the crimes of grin DeVault is
still one of the most hotly anticipated
films of 2018 Newt Scamander is back in
action and this time he's being drafted
by a young Albus Dumbledore to help
bring down the scourge of the Wizarding
World
Gellert Grindelwald the trailer promises
another magical adventure filled with
high stakes wizardry and flying carriage
chases and of course plenty of fantastic
beasts David Yates who directed the
first fantastic beasts and the last four
Harry Potter movies returns to helm the
crimes of Grindelwald look for it on
November 16th Robin Hood Assassin's
Creed heads to Nottingham in the newest
trailer for Robin Hood the latest take
on the legend that's putting the aerial
acrobatics back in archery Kingsman is
Caryn Edgerton stars of the hooded arrow
slinger with Jamie Foxx stepping in as
his right-hand man Little John obviously
this rendition is taking a few liberties
with the source material Little John is
Robin's combat trainer Maid Marion is
Irish instead of English and none of
them seem to be wearing tights you go be
a minder wear tights but we're assuming
it'll make up for all of that with tons
of action and epic bow and arrow Eng
mixed in with just enough romance to
keep everyone's dates happy Robin Hood
is scheduled to hit theaters on November
21st
Aquaman could this be the movie that
defines the new worlds of DC we're ready
for one of these movies to come out and
blow us all away and so far all signs
point to Aquaman being the one to do it
experienced filmmaker James Wan is in
the directing chair and Jason Momoa
seems to have all the right aqua stuff
to play the king of Atlantis the trailer
shows that the film will be pulling from
Geoff Johns 2011 Aquaman
comics which feature cool deep sea
critters called the trench and include a
battle for the throne against Aquaman's
own half-brother norm that's all good
stuff and the Aquaman trailer seems to
showcase plenty of style right now
Aquaman is slated to hit theaters on
December 21st
Elita battle angel December 21st is
shaping up to be a battleground for
box-office dominance not only are Robin
Hood and Aquaman hitting the big screen
that day but they'll do so right
alongside Alita battle angel with Robert
Rodriguez directing from a script
co-written by James Cameron this
adaptation of the popular manga is in
great hands but that hasn't stopped fans
of the source material from getting kind
of nervous why are they so squirrely
three words giant freaky eyes true to
the manga the main character's eyes are
at least three sizes too large or
approximately the size of the Grinch is
hard after he learns the meaning of
Christmas once you start looking past
the obvious though it's hard not to hope
that elite of battle angel could very
well turn out to be a great movie the
trailer shows off a beautifully stylized
future world and if there's a good story
behind it then everyone may just end up
forgetting about those eyes after all
blasts ever since the final scene of
split audiences have been waiting for
the inevitable splendor evil crossover
to materialize now that the first
trailer for the sequel is here titled
glass after samuel l.jackson unbreakable
character it's starting to look like the
weight was worth it the trailer doesn't
hold back on the goods either it jumps
straight into a shot of Jackson's mr.
glass Bruce Willis's David Dunn and
James McAvoy's Kevin crumbs sitting in a
room together
after that the trailer spends most of
its runtime making sure everyone knows
who these people are Dunne is a
bulletproof vigilante Crom is a
schizophrenic demon man and glass is
really really good at planning stuff
finally we get some hints that glass and
crumb are going to team up and done
we'll have to stop their evil schemes
check it out On January 18 2019 Chaz Sam
Billy Batson may not be the most popular
name among the DC lineup but even non
comics readers are bound to know the
name of his alter-ego Shazam the first
trailer for Shazam introduces the young
foster kid who's granted superpowers
like any kid he just wants to have fun
with his new abilities but when a
supervillain Menace starts making his
presence known Billy will have
to get serious to save the world Zachary
Levy seems like a great choice to play
the hero especially since he seems to
have such a great on-screen vibe Dylan
grazer who's playing Billy's foster
brother Freddie Freeman
Shazam strikes theatres sometime in
April 20 19.0 king of the monsters July
rewarded fans with two new looks at
what's to come for Godzilla king of the
monsters the month started with a brief
teaser showing stranger things as Millie
Bobby Brown trying to get in touch with
someone on a radio but the big reveal
came when the full-length trailer for
the movie dropped because this time we
actually got to see all those giant
monsters director Michael Dougherty has
also teased that a character from Kong
Skull Island will show up but we do
bring back one character Kong Scott yeah
you'll have to see the movie hopefully
that character is none other than Kong
himself we'll be able to find out when
Godzilla king of the monsters smashes
into theatres on May 31st 2019
[Music]